[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors d'un rassemblement de jeunes dans
le grill j'intervenais il ya quelques
temps sur leur participation en
politique j'ai été étonné par la
question que tous je dis bien tous m'ont
posé
comment as tu fait pour te sentir
capable légitime de te présenter à une
élection puis devenir mère à l'âge de 18
ans parce que depuis ans non je prend
progressivement ma place au sein de mon
territoire ardéchois et plus
particulièrement à vin vieux village de
500 habitants dans lequel j'ai grandi et
où je suis maintenant mère
et mes mots sont choisis
prendre sa place prendre sa place parce
que je mesure la rapidité avec laquelle
je me suis engagé et la difficulté que
l'on peut avoir à se faire entendre à se
sentir légitime
prendre sa place parce que je sais aussi
la chance que j'ai d'avoir déjà diverses
responsabilités tant au sein de ma
commune qu'au niveau intercommunal où je
préside par exemple en syndicats sur les
questions d'enfance et de jeunesse mais
pour en arriver là et quand je regarde
un petit peu derrière moi
je vois surtout le travail que j'ai dû
fournir et les barrières que j'ai dû
abattre c'est pour ça que je voudrais
vous parler aujourd'hui
d'une des choses qui il me semble est au
coeur de beaucoup de ces barrières
la légitimité
voyez
non cela il faut l'oser et je crois
qu'il représente bien ce qu'est ce qui
empêche ce que permet la légitimité
en effet si je veux aller un petit peu
plus loin je me suis permis de prendre
un risque en l'occurrence le silence
toujours redoutée par les orateurs et
une civile analyse un petit peu parce
que je passe un petit peu tout mon temps
à analyser tout ce que je vois tout ce
que je fais
j'en retire deux éléments qui sont
importants à bien garder en mémoire pour
la suite déjà je suis ici sur cette
scène
j'ai été sélectionné et vous êtes venus
pour m'écouter le cadre l'environnement
extérieur me met en confiance je vais
appeler ça la légitimité externe celle
que l'on porte ensuite
je me sens capable de vous parler j'ai
travaillé en amont
j'ai des messages de fonds à vous faire
passer là il s'agit de la manière dont
moi et moi seul me sens légitime
et je vais naturellement appelé ça la
légitimité interne celle que je me porte
mais
passons tout de suite à la pratique qui
d'entre vous pensent que je suis trop
jeune
j'envoie qui hésite quand même et si je
vous pose cette question c'est parce
qu'elle m'a accompagné tout au long de
ma campagne pour les élections
municipales
si elle ne m'a pas bloqué si je me la
suis jamais vraiment posé géo par contre
la conviction que l a pu être à la
source d'un grand nombre d'auto censure
c'est vrai qui n'a jamais abandonné une
idée parce que jeune parce que trop loin
de la ville parce que femme parce que
j'en sais rien différent
et demain ce ne sera pas moi qui vous
poseraient cette question mais ce sera
la société qui est en train de vous
faire entrer dans une de ces cases avec
toutes les conséquences que cela peut
avoir en termes de préjugés pour moi ça
s'est vérifié
au cours de ma campagne j'ai croisé le
chemin de quelques journalistes qui
m'ont tous
tous posé cette question tous demandé si
je n'étais pas trop jeune et ce qui me
pose problème avec cette question c'est
qu'elle est totalement biaisé la
jeunesse est une fausse question en
jugement a priori qui tenteraient de
nous faire croire que l'âge serait temps
facteur essentiel de compétences
d'expérience
c'est absurde
non derrière est ce que vous n'êtes pas
trop jeune la question qui se pose en
réalité c'est est-ce que vous vous
sentez capable d'assumer ses
responsabilités
dans la première question je parle dans
la tribu quelque chose sur lequel je
n'ai aucune emprise n'en déplaise aux
vendeurs de crèmes antirides dans la
seconde
je questionne en revanche une qualité ça
peut être la motivation certaine
compétence on peut y mettre plein de
choses là dedans mais surtout
je me délit de toute cette pression
sociale en l'occurrence sur la jeunesse
enfin à mon tour
tout 0e question
est ce que vous vous ne seriez pas trop
jeune
que pourriez vous répondre à ça
probablement peu de choses intéressantes
et on voit là qu'il est difficile de se
poser une bonne question oui la bonne
question celle
qui ne porte pas sa propre réponse mais
qui ouvre sur la réflexion celle qui ne
vous bloque pas mais qui vous fait
avancer et tant qu'on est dans les
questions se posaient des questions
voilà un autre enjeu majeur de la
légitimité
parce qu'avant d'avoir en projet et de
se lancer dans un projet quel qu'il soit
encore faut-il en avoir l'idée
ainsi il a fallu qu'à un moment je me
demande si j'avais envie de devenir
maire de ma commune et si j'ai répondu à
cette question
comme si je me sentais capable d'assumer
ses responsabilités ce n'est pas je
crois le fruit du hasard non au
contraire j'ai la conviction que au
coeur de la question de la légitimité
se situe celle de la confiance
beaucoup de choses se sont jouées pour
moi
il ya quatre ans quand j'ai rencontré un
homme formidable qui je dois beaucoup
sur ma manière de penser et d'aborder la
politique
christian d'humains il était directeur
de cabinet d'une mairie proche de chez
moi et j'ai eu la chance je pense que je
peux dire la chance de l'avoir comme
maître de stage
j'avais 16 ans à l'époque et ce qui m'a
touché c'est qu'il m'a fait confiance
j'étais pas très compétent c'était ma
toute première expérience
professionnelle je découvrais beaucoup
de choses mais il m'a laissé la
possibilité d'agir de faire
ça a été en choc par rapport au système
scolaire tech que le jeu que tel que je
le connaissais
c'est vrai quand il fallait que je
rédige en courrier que j'appelle en
service que j'aille sur le terrain
il me laissait la possibilité de le
faire et il me laisser me débrouiller
pour arriver jusqu'au bout
ce que je veux montrer par là
c'est que
la confiance est d'abord une question
relationnel elle se forge à travers les
rencontres à travers les interactions
sociales
ainsi
parce qu'on m'a fait confiance il ya
quelques années
j'ai décidé à mon tour de me faire
confiance aujourd'hui
et je crois que ce facteur est un
facteur qui était déterminant dans mon
parcours la confiance en soi à travers
l'autre je me dépasse je m'oblige je me
mets en difficulté
et je veux insister sur ces mots à
travers l'autre parce que l'autre ne
fait pas tout en tout cas il n'a pas
tout fait pour moi est au coeur de la
construction de ma confiance je voudrais
vous parler
d'autre chose qui qui est
l'échec
parce que ces semaines de stage ont
aussi été particulièrement déterminante
dans mon rapport à l'échec au cours de
ma scolarité assez lisse il faut le dire
je n'avais jamais vraiment envisagé ou
plutôt j'ai évité le risque par peur de
l'imprévu et une fille née de l'échec
mais dans un environnement nouveau et
avec la confiance que l'on m'a fait je
me suis dit qu'il fallait que je me
laisse la possibilité de me planter
et c'est aussi ça prendre sa place
c'est osé se donner droit d'essayer de
prendre des risques mais attention je
donne je ne vous donne pas là non plus
en blanc seing pour faire n'importe quoi
sans être inquiétés
parce que ce n'est pas ça prendre
confiance en soi non
la confiance
se gagne par la manière dont on traite
avec les imprévus autant les bonnes
nouvelles et les réussites que les moins
bonnes nouvelles ou les crises
ainsi
je m'attelle à traiter chaque élément
positif comme négatif quand ils arrivent
face à moi de la même manière
comme une opportunité
comme on essai à transformer
et pour ça
j'ai prendre en exemple en exemple tout
récent tellement récent que je suis pas
sûr de l'avoir tout à fait digéré
d'ailleurs
juillet dernier des pluies diluviennes
s'abattent sur ma commune
je m'y attendais absolument pas en
dix heures plus de 10 cm d'eau par mètre
carré avec bien sûr toutes les
dégradations qui s'en suivent
cette situation
je les ai d'abord mal vécue parce que
comment dire
certains dégâts pu être évité si je
n'avais pas si j'avais au plus tôt
réalisés tels ou tels travaux
je le savais
j'avais prévu de le faire
je n'en avais pas mesuré l'urgence
est donc je vais d'abord vécu comme un
échec à faire le tour de mon village
sans pouvoir rien faire à l'instant t
avoir des habitants qui ment gueule
parce qu'ils ont 20 cm d'eau dans leur
garage et ils ont probablement raison je
sais pas si j'étais responsable et à
quel point j'étais responsable à
l'époque mais en tout cas je m'en
sentais responsable et donc sur cette
situation qui était difficile
j'ai dû assez vite rebondir
ainsi
cet événement est arrivé certes avec
toutes ses conséquences négatives
mais maintenant ça a été aussi
l'occasion pour moi de
mesurer un petit peu les limites de mes
réseaux d'eaux pluviales de les avoir
vus mise à rude épreuve
alors le soir je suis rentré en mairie
je me suis assis à mon bureau et je me
suis dit ok maintenant on va réfléchir à
la suite
les rénovations
les investissements et là
je ne vois plus cheikh en tant que
résignation mais en tant qu'opportunité
peut-on encore là parler d'échec
et c'est cet état d'esprit que je
souhaite transmettre parce que quand on
l'appliqué il permet de dépasser les
doutes des barrières tout un tas de
barrières
il ya l'envers ce
avoir conscience que
les chèques je fais partie intégrante de
notre vie permet d'éviter de tomber dans
un écueil inverse
l'excès de confiance parce que prendre
sa place
ce n'est pas sa foi reçue rentrer aun
qui écraserait tout sur son passage non
une place
c'est un endroit délimiter
ainsi le message est là prenez votre
place
connaissez vos limites
accepter de ne pas connaître apprécier à
prendre
voilà maintenant
un an que je suis devenu élu et je crois
pouvoir dire sans trop me tromper que je
suis déjà devenu bavard ce qui implique
deux choses déjà que je devrais son gm
taire pour ne pas monopoliser le reste
de votre journée et ensuite que je le
ferais tout de même pas sans vous parler
d'une dernière chose parce que si je
vous ai parlé tout ça
si j'ai décidé de d'utiliser cet espace
de parole pour vous questionner sur la
confiance que l'on se porte à soi que le
supporter aux autres la légitimité les
liens entre tout ça c'est parce que ces
questions ont été
cruciales face en état d'esprit qui
s'efface chez moi
la timidité
parce que oui il ya de ça deux ans
j'aurais été tout bonnement incapables
de parler devant nous
et je l'interprète aujourd'hui comme en
manque évident de confiance jeu me
sentais pas forcément à ma place dans
mes relations
il m'aura fallu en déclic une pensée une
personne quelqu'un qui m'a fait
comprendre que je pouvais prendre la
parole que je pouvait assumer mes
combats mes échecs aussi
être responsable et ce déclic je vous le
souhaite qu'ils passent par ces clés que
vous pouvez vous approprier ou
pas rentrer vos proches
et d'ailleurs parmi eux
lequel pourrait vous faire confiance
plus que vous ne vous fait confiance
vous même
et corps est il à vous apporter
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]